I think I can survive because they're
loves sugar with sugar grits then I can
with salt I don't think so I don't think
it no you cannot get looser as a girl
who grew up in a very southern household
I know that there are some few parents
you just don't mess with chicken and
waffles greens and ham hocks salt and
grits but apparently there's this thing
called sugar grits so I've asked some of
my co-workers to come in and test out
the age-old debate under vs. salt grits
it's almost a cream of wheat but like
that with soft sounds like blasphemy
grapes are not meant to be sweet they
are savory they're close your eyes you
got eggs cheese grits do you put your
spoon in mm-hm
you pull it out it's got this long
cheese too oh my god in eggs grits and
then you just bite that seriously that's
gross no one should eat that I feel like
I can eat three bites of this and I'd be
like I'm done this is too much hmm you
know based on food makes you and what
they put it in we just need a third
person okay clearly we haven't settled
this debate so I'm gonna go around the
office and see what everybody else makes
I don't really see the point like this
will never be on the menu anywhere okay
here's my thing
grits aren't oatmeal I mean it's good it
tastes like cornbread batter
blasphemy we kind of taste like I'll
keep popcorn oh I don't like it
team sugar do sugar though I'm saying it
tastes like [ __ ]
it tastes pretty good though I don't
want to talk about it I grew up with
salt grits I grew up with a dude to be
honest though I'm not even joking I
didn't know sugar grits for it was a
thing until you decided to make this
video
oh you like it tastes like a like a poor
man's oatmeal like you ran out of salt
and so you just thought sugar it might
be like a good substitute only
acceptable if you dev sure you don't
have a friend right now Matt check it
assault witness the best um she said
sulla it's can we just you said it well
we had some people convert from salsa
[ __ ] there but it looks like majority
wins and that is so great
[Music]